inga you have done something quite
remarkable very recently in the worst
economic climate since the Great
Depression you have closed a capital
campaign for Yale University raising
over 3.8 billion dollars how did you
manage those challenges and how did you
succeed well I have to admit it was an
adventure and not one that we had
planned for you know I've been in
development for a long time and when you
have a campaign there's always a
recession in there so you kind of you
know go with the flow there but this one
was so different as we all you know
experienced and I will never forget
october two thousand and eight which is
when everything came to a grinding halt
now luckily we were ahead way ahead of
our schedule for the campaign we were in
year three already and we ran about a
year ahead of schedule but because we
were thinking we were doing so well in
june of 2008 we increased the goal to
three and a half billion and then came
October what was so new and different
and scary about that time was that this
financial crisis was something that was
completely unpredictable on how what
would happen next it created a
tremendous sense of uncertainty nobody
knew where this was going nobody knew
where the freefall would end and that
was the most there was the most
difficult part to deal with because
obviously our donors even those who may
not have been completely you know
affected by this crisis there was the
uncertainty they didn't know what was
going to happen and so for about two
years it was just almost impossible to
get people to make new commitments now
obviously we were still you know
determined to reach the goal and so we
shifted focus and we
really shifted focus on not there many
many many different campaign priorities
that we had but we focused on the core
we said okay we need gifts to financial
aid we need gifts for professorships
gifts that built the endowment and help
in this financial crisis and we took a
in a very tough look at what we could
accomplish and what not so you have
heard the president speak about you know
we stopped our capital projects you know
almost all building you know got stopped
but we figured out there were few that
we might be able to finish and so we
said we concentrate on those so the the
secret behind it was that we were very
very focused as a staff now the secret
behind the relationship with our donors
was that we didn't drop them when the
bad times came we initially they didn't
want to see us because they thought we
wanted to ask him for a gift but once
they realized that we just wanted to
maintain the relationship stay in touch
expressed that we understand that this
is a difficult time you know we were
able to stay involved have them stayed
off with Yale and then the last year of
the campaign happened and somehow people
either were used to the new normal or
they you know they saw where things were
going for themselves and they were so
dedicated to Yale that they didn't want
to miss participating in the campaign so
while the first two years of the crisis
we are giving dropped significantly in
the last year of the campaign our donors
gave 862 million dollars this is by far
the largest amount that was ever given
to Yale in a given year and you know it
shows the commitment that our donors
head so I have to say the credit does
not go to the staff the credit goes to
our adore nurse to the gallant office